Speaker 1: . Let's talk about the New York
City mayoral primary. Yesterday, we had the
Democratic mayoral primary in New York City
and the Republican mayoral primary in New
York City. There were high hopes among some
that former Democratic presidential candidate
Andrew Yang would do well in the Democratic
primary. Can a New York City mayoral race.
He came out to a fast start polling really,
really well in early polls, although that
started to fade. Part of the belief that the
fade of Andrew Yang was because of early name
recognition. He jumped ahead because of early
name recognition from the Democratic primary.
Also, questions about, I guess we would call
it, the authenticity of Andrew Yang as a New
Yorker. And there were all sorts of kind of
xenophobic overtones to that. There is no
question that there was an aspect of the opposition
to accepting Andrew Yang as a real New Yorker,
came from some anti Asian xenophobia. And
also there was the sense that Andrew Yang,
having lived out of the city for a long time,
was not a real New Yorker in that sense as
well, disaggregating some xenophobia from
the accurate understanding of Andrew Yang's
residence, a complicated and difficult thing
and important not to invalidate any aspect
of that, because all of it were important.
All of those aspects were relevant. But ultimately,
it did not go well. For Andrew Yang, the results
as we have them right now have Eric Adams
leading. It is a ranked choice election. And
right now you have Eric Adams leading at just
shy of 32 percent on the Democratic side,
with Maya Wiley up close to 10 points behind
at 22 percent. Kathryn Garcia closely behind.
Maya Wiley in third place at 19 and a half
percent, and then pretty significantly further
down with only about a third of the support
of the leading candidate, Eric Adams, Andrew
Yang at eleven point seven percent, Scott
Stringer and Diane Morales combining for just
shy of eight percent. Over on the Republican
side, Curtis sleazoid, quite a well-known
face and figure in New York City. Now, for
decades, of course, of Guardian Angels fame,
Curtis Sliva easily winning the Republican
primary with about 72 percent of the vote
over Fernando Mateo. Here is video of Andrew
Yang, who is all about math and the numbers
rightly coming out last night and saying,
I don't have the numbers, I simply don't have
the numbers. Take a listen to this campaign.
Speaker 3: What do you all know? I am a numbers
guy, right? I'm someone who traffics in what's
happening by the numbers. And I am not going
to be the next mayor of New York City based
upon the numbers that have come in tonight.
I am conceding this race, though we're not
sure ultimately who the next mayor is going
to be. But whoever that person is, I will
be very happy to work with them.
Speaker 1: Now, a bunch of people coming out
and saying, you know what? What what pomposity
from Andrew Yang, why would the eventual mayor
work on anything with the fourth place finisher
in the Democratic primary? I didn't see it
that way. I saw it simply as an act of good
faith. I don't think that is a big deal. I
think the more interesting story, however,
is how New York City is an interesting place
in that the voters really did not seem to
care about the name recognition of Andrew
Yang. It helped him early, but it did not
carry him to the finish line. And now we are
going to see the general election get going.
New York City, interesting as a it's not necessarily
a barometer nationally, but there are a lot
of things in New York City that relate to
issues that many cities across the country
are dealing with. There are questions now
about how to deal with what are widely perceived
to be short term, but certainly upticks in
certain types of. Crime and later today, Joe
Biden is going to have a big event related
to gun violence. There are also questions
about, you know, there's been a a sort of
bifurcation at the local and semi local level
about how politics should be focused in the
United States. There are all these national
issues and cultural issues that are getting
a lot of attention when you watch Fox News
and CNN and MSNBC and there have been attempts
to insert those as the important issues into
local races. In some places, to a degree,
it's worked where local races become about
will the city council boycott Israel or will
we make a statement about critical race theory
as examples? But what I am seeing in New York
City is that voters really seem to care much
more about local economic issues, local issues
of public transit and rent prices, and really
that nitty gritty. Which takes me back to
the James Carville 1990s perspective of it's
the economy, stupid. It's not seeming to me
like making local races about national, cultural
or even irrelevant to the local race, foreign
policy issues that seems to be coming through
in the results that we're seeing in New York
City. So we're going to follow the race, even
though it's a local race, because it has a
lot of national implications. Let me know
your thoughts about what happened to Andrew
Yáng in New York City. I laid out what I
think held him back. Let me know what you
think. You can find me on Twitter at David
Pakman. We're going to take a quick break.
And we've got really just a packed program
for
you today. Remember that The David Pakman
Show is an independent media program does
depend on your support, I would love it if
you grabbed a membership on my website. Join
Pakman Dotcom.